là on est là ah tout de
même
Alice un peu plus tard un peu plus tôt
par l'avion ou par le métro
ou
simplement en prenant tout son
temps les gens comme nous ne savent pas
ce qui fait avancer leur pas mais
on s'en
va on s'en
va pour Paris pour ton pour Chezelle ou
pour n'importe où quand on a le cœur à
genou la destination on s'en fout on dit
qu'on s'en fout mais mon il chaque
remariage est
un les gens comme
nous ils
sont tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
seul
seul tout
seul mais pas plus que
ceux qui sont
cocus et qui se tisent
pour ne
pas couper en deux la table l'armoire
les deux
ch seul tout
seul pas plus que certains qui
boivent pour oublier qu'ils
boivent et
qui quand ils sont
montagun traite les ivrognes
d'pav seul tout seul pas plus que ceux
qui ont bâti les
cathédrales et qui le ciel plein les
yeux meurent d'une indigestion
d'étoile seul tout seul pas plus que le
Fils de l'homme au pied du
calvaire
qui sait que sa mort ne peut que servir
l'orgueil de son
père seul tout seul pas plus que ceux
qui pédg d'un air très grave puis qui
vont dans d'autres lieux se faire
fouetter comme des esclaves seul tout
seul pas plus que Cell qui vont de
névrose en
névrose qui d'hôpital en bordel crèvent
un soir d'uneur d' seul tout seul mais
pas plus que moi qui vit ma vie sous des
lanternes pour cacher qu'il y a en moi
un cœur gris comme une caserne seul tout
seul tout le monde est seul tout seul
tout seul tout
seul Alice